hawkeye and i are working on a case uh  and we needed to use the bathroom uh he  reheated so we were by the house and we  dropped in no big deal working on a  terrific  he's my partner  we're not  partners or  friends slash partners i wouldn't really  describe us as friends  someone used my laptop to sign out of my  work account ten minutes ago  any thoughts kate  hawkeye  oh he'll he'll never get anything out of  him  see cb1 has trouble opening up nobody  calls me cb1 i'm just trying to know for  a second probably some early childhood  thing  he thinks he doesn't tell me much but he  ends up kind of virtuous  um but yeah i think it's cause i'm  generally just pretty chill you know i'm  not like oh my god hawkeye  definitely not joe  by the way thank you  for saving the world  don't mention it